beyond the scope of light beyond reach
Oh John
possibly away
and you're seeking in safe
on April 7th 2015 your copy of Dark
Souls 2 will be receiving for free an
update including new NPCs new enemies
gameplay improvements new item
descriptions and improved online
matchmaking in other words the entire
experience will be receiving a layer of
Polish that from software seems to think
it deserves in addition to patching the
core experience that you already own the
improved game and its DLC is being
repackaged and re-released for the
next-gen systems if you purchase another
copy for your ps4 your Xbox one or your
PC you'll get all the things I just
mentioned so you'll get the patched
experience plus a few things that will
only exist because of your improved
hardware now we all know that there were
a lot of compromises made for the ps3
and the Xbox 360 so here's hoping for
something that is akin to the
pre-release graphics we saw in the demo
for this next-gen version Namco has
listed additional upgrades to graphics
sound and performance as well as an
increase in the maximum online players
allowed in a single session from 4 to 6
essentially you get your own small army
in the game with you again these last
two things are only possible because of
the improved hardware so that's what
you're paying for
if you decide to buy it again for your
more powerful systems unfortunately
those playing on PC will have to buy it
again if they want these improved
graphics and I'll explain that sad fact
to you later in the video
but for now let's look at these
improvements they've listed and let's go
a little bit more in depth personally I
feel like Dark Souls 2 is one of those
good games that's a few small tweaks
away from being a great game
mechanically it's all there but I found
myself thinking that there are so many
little things they could do to polish
the experience and I guess that's what
they're doing with scholar of the first
sin so when I look at this small list of
improvements they plan to make in 2015 I
see a window into the ways from thinks
their game might be lacking so let's
investigate that let's try and guess
what they think is lacking and I'm
curious to see what you think as well
first up they're adding new NPCs for and
I quote an enhanced story experience
this is my favorite part of the
announcement now I'm a little bit biased
considering I built this channel around
great stories that were told in Dark
Souls so far though the best stories in
Dark Souls 2 have been told in the dlc
and that's saying something because
barely any of those dlc stories have
been told through npc interactions and
dialogue take my last video for example
it's about a lawn and the iron king and
it's a narrative that exists entirely
because of item descriptions the
environment and the characters you fight
I made an 11 minute video out of that
without any in-game dialogue and without
any character interaction and I think
it's the best video I've ever made if
you compare these stories in the DLC to
those in the core game you realize that
the NPC's in this game lack substance
they have lines and lines of dialogue
yet in my opinion none of them compare
to the stories they told in the dlc dlc
that doesn't even have interactable NPCs
and that says something that tells me
that from is looking to improve this in
their patch and i can still tell the
stories about the characters like luca
teal and pate don't get me wrong but
these characters experience little to no
character development they're barely
present in majula
and their stories have no real twists
that exists in previous games characters
like me i think that from sees
characters as an area the game could
improve and I hope we get characters
that are fully fleshed out and fully
realized like so many of the characters
deserve to be the DLC we received proves
that from is capable of crafting human
characters that we relate to and I want
this to be fully realized with
interactable NPCs so hopefully that's
what they have in mind second on the
list of improvements is that from is
looking to augment item descriptions
this is really interesting
there aren't many games that would
advertise the fact that they're changing
the text of their items and this shows
that they actually realize how important
these descriptions are
for telling a story as someone who's
trawled through all of these
descriptions multiple times it's fairly
obvious that they could be written
better some don't make as much sense
because they've been translated from
Japanese but more than that so many
descriptions end with a question or a
statement of confusion take the rulers
sword for example the Great King shut
himself away and was reduced to a mere
shell just what was it he yearned to
protect take a look for yourself through
the descriptions and you'll be amazed
how many of them waste space with
pointless questions the purpose of these
questions is to direct the player
towards seeking an answer but
unfortunately the game itself doesn't
offer enough answers with this upcoming
patch I think this is a problem they
should fix I'd guess that they're not
looking to paint a new narrative with
these descriptions rather they really
should clarify the murky narrative that
already does exist and please tell me
why one stain is and Dark Souls 2 please
thirdly gameplay improvements if I ask
you hey what do you think needs to be
fixed most in Dark Souls 2 what's the
first thing you would come up with
what's that one fix that you have in
your mind that would be easy to
implement but would make a world of
difference I'm really curious to hear
your thoughts and I know a lot of you
feel the need to vent so please write
your thoughts down in the comments we
all have our gripes with the game but
there are some fixes that really should
just be in there personally I think of
two things first up first
I think of soul memory Dark Souls 2 s
online matches us with people who have
the same soul memory as us which was a
great system while we were leveling up
but it's completely decimated late-game
PvP and replayability because of soul
memory late-game PvP s have no real
reason to stop leveling up their
character resulting in an end game full
of characters who aren't pvping with the
same stats this could easily be fixed
what if soul memory was a thing for your
first playthrough but was removed in a
new game+ playthrough for people who
want to PvP what if you had to opt in to
soul memory or soul level and decide
what one you want to use I've solved
these problems with about five minutes
of thought and from software should too
they've actually listed improved online
matchmaking as a fix that they want to
implement so I hope that this is what
they're referring to
another gameplay change for example I
wish they'd make is removing the ability
to buy life gems from millennia in
majula personally I think that life gems
should be a limited item if life gems
were limited I would value them a lot
more because they're not limited I use
them between every little fight and I
topped myself up between every encounter
and I never use my Estes unless I'm in a
battle as a result there is no stress
that comes from running out of estes
between battles and the only way you can
die in this game is to be overwhelmed in
battle and not able to heal in time you
never die from lack of healing in Dark
Souls 1 it was actually an experience to
run out of healing and in Dark Souls 2
that element is completely removed
because life gems are infinite I miss
that and I think that should be changed
there are a bunch more gameplay
improvements that they could implement
but let's move on to the fact that they
want to add new enemies which is
probably the most exciting thing in the
trailer we see two new encounters one is
with the red drake in hides tower of
flame once dean the dragon slayer
clearly isn't doing his job here which
is interesting still would like a bit
more information on him by the way and
the second encounter is very intriguing
have a listen
others come
as
this last line answers some questions it
proves that we are a monarch just like
the Kings before us however we have done
what none of them could have in the DLC
we United the Crown's gaining our power
over undeath just like I said in my dlc
explained ending video there is yet more
for our character to achieve and I'm
glad I was right in predicting this DLC
because it seems like this is where Dark
Souls 2 will get its proper ending in
all of history not one undead has stood
as far as we have and it seems like this
upcoming patch could give us the answers
we crave as for the creature that the
character in the trailer is facing I
have no idea what it is
it's spooky though it has this one red
eye that reminds me of Manas from Dark
Souls 1 but that's about as far as I go
my best guess is that it's some
representation of Manas just like the
dark Queens were moving on to the
narrator if I had to guess I'd say that
it's aldea vendrick's brother this image
of him bears vendrick's likeness plus
aldea is reputed to be the more studious
scholarly type plus there's this big
book in modulars mansion that is just
begging to be an entry portal for some
type of DLC it seems like we are going
to learn what the scholar of the first
sin knows and if I had to guess what the
first sin was it would likely be the
event that began all of these cycles in
the first place perhaps the discovery of
the Lord Souls or seath's betrayal of
the Dragons or the linking of the fire I
guess we'll see come April 7th overall I
hope this gave you some better idea of
what you might want to expect from the
patch next year at the very least the
game you already own will be receiving
improvements and that's nothing to
complain about in regards to buying it
again any promises of graphical
improvements have made me wary based on
past experiences and I recommend you be
as well on the other hand the DLC was
incredible for the price and they are
giving you these improvements at no
extra costs where many other companies
would release a game of the Year Edition
and expect you to buy it again so it
does so consume a goodwill to
in all this stuff that some might argue
should have been there from the
beginning
sure they expect you to buy it again for
your next-gen system but that's to be
expected I think the only shitty thing
so far is that there's going to be two
versions of the PC Edition one with the
updated graphics and one without if I
understand this correctly it's because
the old version of the game runs on
DirectX 9 and the new version is going
to be released on DirectX 11 as a result
the PC user base is going to be split
between those playing the old version
and those playing the new version the
Japanese website has confirmed that
these player bases will be on different
servers theoretically PC is all one
platform and it is very odd that they're
treating the two versions of the game as
separate but technically it seems like
this problem exists because updating a
PC games with all its saves from a dx9
version to a dx11 version might be
impossible I don't know I've heard that
some games allow you to boot them up in
DirectX 9 or DirectX 11 maybe this is
the route they should go with instead
and hopefully there is some sort of
compromise made for the poor PC players
who don't feel like buying the game
again for updated graphics that their PC
can already handle but what do you guys
think about all this let me know Souls
should be getting some good revivals in
the coming months in December you'll be
able to move your Dark Souls PC saves
from games for Windows Live to
Steamworks and in March we're getting
blood-borne and in April we have a
refreshed version of Dark Souls 2 to
jump into there's good times ahead and
if you haven't already please subscribe
so I can keep you up to date on all this
stuff and if you've already subscribed
then thank you for watching my videos
and I'll see you next time
you